productions hollywoodiennes.
Camille Gris-Roy.
- Parmi les films en français
projetés au TIFF, plusieurs
le sont en première mondiale.
- Je m'ennuyais de vous autres.
- À Dave!
- (en coeur): À Dave!
- Dont "Viking", du réalisateur
québécois Stéphane Lafleur.
Et "La Gravité", du Franco-
burkinabé Cédric Ido.
L'histoire d'un quartier
de banlieue, dont l'équilibre
sera bousculé par un événement
cosmique.
CÉDRIC IDO, réalisateur,
"La Gravité"
- Justement, j'osaent, j'osais r
que Toronto le prenne.
Parce que pour moi c'est
vraiment le festival qu'il
fallait à ce film. C'est un
où les gens viennent
vraiment voir les films.
- Le Français Christian Carion,
lui, est venu présenter son film
"Une belle course", qui met
en scène les acteurs Dany Boon
et Line Renaud, traversant les
rues de Paris en taxi.
- Avenue de Chabannes à
Courbevoie.
- Faut traverser tout Paris,
vous êtes au courant?
Cette première projection devant
un public nord-américain,
principalement anglophone,
angoissait un peu le
réalisateur, mais il se réjouit
d'avoir cette tribune.
CHRISTIAN CARION, réalisateur,
"Une belle course"
- La culture c'est la langue
Donc que des films circulent
dans leur langue maternelle,
c'est très important.
- Les films de France sont ainsi
nombreux à s'être taillé
une place dans la programmatpron
du TIFF cette année. On compte
près d'une cinquantaine de
productions ou co-productions
françaises, selon l'organisme
de promotion UniFrance.
DANIELA ELSTNER,ELSTNER,
directrice, UniFrance
- Par rapport au nombre de films
dans leur totalité à Toronto,
c'est un record. Donc le ratio
en fait. Donc on est extrêmement
bien représentés et les artistes
se sont beaucoup déplacés,
donc viennent nombreux pour être
là, présents avec leurs films
par ce que c'est vraiment
important.
- Parmi les quelques productions
canadiennes en français, il y a
le film Rosie. Un projet à part
puisqu'il s'agit en réalité
d'un film bilingue. Il raconte
l'histoire d'une orphéline
autochtone, forcée d'aller vivre
avec sa tante francophone
qu'elle ne connaît pas,
jouée par Mélanie Bray.
- C'est mieux qu'elle soit avec
vous, vous êtes de la parenté.
Your auntie is so excited
to take you home.
- L'actrice montréalaise
regrette qu'on ne voit pas
plus de ces films bilingues
au Canada.
MÉLANIE BRAY, actrice, "ROSIE"
- c'est bizarre, parce qu'on est
tous dans le même pays, mais on
vit vraiment dans deux mondes
différents, on dirait
les anglophones et les
francophones souvent.
- "Mais les festivals comme